[Música]
pasamos a las noticias de la salud y
para ello mar Romero sala mar Buen día
para usted Buenos días Ángela hoy vamos
a empezar con un repaso histórico sobre
cómo el mundo de la salud ha clasificado
a la población lgbtiq más como personas
enfermas es importante recordar este
tipo de clasificaciones porque parece
que sean inverosímiles pero hasta hace
nada estaba pasando eso Entonces bueno
en un contexto de retroceso de derechos
es importante recordar Cómo eran las
cosas antes no solemos pensar en la
ciencia en la salud como algo monolítico
como algo que nunca cambia porque está
basado en hechos científicos pero la
verdad es que siempre ha bebido de las
ideologías de los prejuicios de las
formas de ver el mundo y especialmente
la medicina occidental en ese sentido
hacia las personas
lgbtiq más pues Ana pensado se ha
categorizado muchas veces desde una
patologización desde una consideración
de que es una enfermedad porque al final
digamos que se definen lo sano como eso
que es normal lo normal es el
heterosexual entre todas las comillas
por supuesto y lo que se sale de esa
normalidad es lo que lo que está enfermo
no En ese sentido repasamos las
clasificaciones que le dio durante mucho
tiempo la asociación estadounidense de
psiquiatría a la homosexualidad
particularmente en Estados Unidos porque
era pues la más grande que existe en el
mundo y es la que sirve de referencia
para muchísimas otras en 1952 era
considerada una alteración sociopática
de la personalidad en el 68 se
consideraba una desviación sexual Esto
no se retiró hasta 1973 después de
muchísimos años de activismo por parte
precisamente de las personas y de los
colectivos
lgbti más y además Igualmente Aunque lo
retiró como una enfermedad seguía
mencionando algo que se llamaba
homosexualidad egodisónica que
básicamente significaba que ser
homosexual podía causar aflicciones en
la salud finalmente en el 87 también se
retiró en cambio la Organización Mundial
de la Salud que es la otra organización
de referencia en este sentido no lo
retiró hasta
1990 hace apenas 33 años pero dejar de
considerar las vidas trans como unas
vidas enfermas entre unas comillas
gigantes pues tuvo que tomar muchísimo
más tiempo más tuvimos que esperar Sí y
de hecho todavía ni siquiera estamos
completamente ahí diríamos no En la
Organización Mundial de la Salud también
lo despatologizó en 2019 hace nada Hace
cuatro años pero es que antes se
describía como un trastorno mental
entonces revisamos también esas
descripciones se describía el
transexualismo Digamos como algo como el
deseo de ser integrante del sexo opuesto
una idea una incomodidad inadecuación
con el sexo anatómico y el deseo también
de tener una cirugía o una terapia
hormonal para adecuarse al género
deseado y también describía el
travestismo como un trastorno mental
describiéndolo como vestir prendas del
sexo opuesto ahora sabemos que las vidas
trans no tienen por qué desear ningún
tratamiento ni ningún tratamiento
quirúrgico necesariamente también
sabemos que el género es mucho más que
la ropa así que bueno por suerte estas
definiciones ya no se incluyen en esos
catálogos de la Organización Mundial de
la Salud pero es cierto que hay
colectivos trans que han criticado que
no es suficiente porque todavía se sigue
caracterizando bajo el capítulo de salud
sexual bajo la incongruencia de género y
pues hay muchas personas trans que dicen
no ser incongruentes que en nada en ese
sentido no entonces por eso Bueno es un
camino que todavía se está caminando
pero con mucha dificultad mar solamente
la semana pasada transitando por la
calle me entregaron panfletos sobre
terapias de conversión que están
prohibidas en muchas partes del mundo y
otras están luchando para prohibirlas la
actualidad en conclusión es que sigue
siendo muy compleja para las personas de
la comunidad diversa Sí en muchísimos
aspectos y centrándonos en el campo de
salud Precisamente lo que comentabas de
las terapias de conversión hay una
infinidad de países donde todavía son
legales no es decir donde es todavía no
hay ninguna prohibición explícita en
este sentido De hecho están prohibidas
explícitamente en un puñado apenas de
países Aunque por suerte hay algunos en
los que por suerte se está debatiendo no
Colombia por ejemplo es uno es uno de
ellos pero al final bebé de la misma
idea de que una persona diversa está
enferma y que necesita un tratamiento
para volver a la normalidad Pero además
no es la única Arista en el campo de la
salud en este sentido no las personas
intersexuales por ejemplo están
sometidas a procedimientos quirúrgicos
desde su infancia y a lo largo de toda
su vida para intentarlos hacer encajar
en alguna casilla sin tener claro no al
final su propio consentimiento su propia
voluntad de identificación de género por
ejemplo Y por supuesto en las vidas
trans eso también es una infinidad de
violencias hay países que todavía
requieren la mayoría de hecho exámenes
psicológicos para las personas trans
para decidir si realmente pueden hacer
su cambio de nombre o su cambio de
género es decir que hay un médico que al
final tiene la decisión final sobre tu
identidad de género o hay muchísimos
países que piden que se hayan pasado por
cirugías de reasignación de género para
formalizar digamos en los papeles esa
transición y eso pues no tendría por qué
ser así repetimos al final es someter
estos cuerpos a las violencias médicas
inauditas bueno es una cuestión de
autopercepción como usted bien dice mar
las discriminaciones sobre la población
lgbtiq más tienen consecuencias sobre la
salud hablemos más sobre esto sí al
final lo que es importante es cambiar
este punto de vista no por ejemplo como
mencionábamos que se consideraba esa
homosexualidad ecodistónica que era ser
homosexual traía aflicciones lo que
tenemos que cambiar es esa consideración
mirar lo distinto y pensar que al final
vivir en un mundo homófobo vivir en un
mundo transfóbico es lo que generan las
aflicciones y los problemas de salud
para estas personas no y no el propio
cuerpo ni la propia orientación aquí hay
las conclusiones de un informe de la
organización Panamericana de la salud
que Recuerda que las personas lgbtiq más
tienen más incidencia en problemas de
Salud Mental como depresión o ansiedad
más abuso de más uso de tabaco más
estrés crónico que sabemos que el
cortisol Que eso genera tiene muchas
implicaciones en la salud de las
personas y que también están
desconectados de los servicios de salud
No de hecho trajimos unos datos para
ejemplificar para terminar esto son
datos incompletos Pero bueno digamos que
los hombres gay tienen un 54% más de
riesgo de ser diagnosticados de cáncer
el 70% es la tasa en las mujeres
bisexuales faltaría ver en el resto
digamos de personas de estas poblaciones
no pero muestra las consecuencias al
final de esta discriminación de por
ejemplo más consumo de tabaco de tener
condiciones socioeconómicas más bajas
pero también de no acercarse tanto a las
consultas de salud precisamente por
miedo a recibir esta discriminación con
consecuencias sobre los cuerpos sobre la
salud verdaderamente incalculables bueno
Y la verdad es que la manera de
solucionar estos temas es ser poniéndolo
sobre la mesa y hablándolos sin embargo
mar y y con esto pues su conclusión
los más conservadores de la sociedad de
todavía piensa en que hablar sobre estos
temas constituye un adoctrinamiento de
los más pequeños Así que sobre esto que
tendríamos que decir claro al final yo
creo que las vidas
lgbtiq más las vidas diversas en
identificación de género o en
orientación sexual no dejan de existir
porque no hablemos de ellas y no hablar
de ellas de hecho siempre a la raíz de
todos estos problemas de salud por
ejemplo de estreses de problemas de
salud mental de problemas de salud
física que vienen luego Así que en ese
sentido no hablar de ellas no es no es
ninguna solución para nada hablar de
ellas más que adoctrinales abrir las
puertas para que todo el mundo pueda
vivir su vida plenamente que al final es
vivirla saludablemente también pues me
alegra agradezco muchísimo feliz fin de
semana feliz fin de semana